[Music]
genius our five hopeful cooks have
nervously entered the culinary arena now
they've each brought their favorite item
from their kitchen at home to help them
here today
judging two rounds of combat is a legend
in the culinary world Edward Lee so what
can our contestants expect for today's
challenges all right today we're pushing
our cooks to the limit with a special
seafood challenge the three cooks who do
the best are gonna move on to the next
round
where I have a pantry full of
ingredients inspired by America Asia
India and France so in round one Edward
will be getting our contestants to
demonstrate their skills using shellfish
only the three best will progress to the
final so let's reveal today's ingredient
contestants please lift your cloches
it's scallops before AdWords sets the
challenge let's hear some tips from the
incredibly talented Gordon Ramsay right
today you'll be working with these
incredible scallops
guess what us fishermen land 36 million
pounds of scarves a year that has a
value of 440 million dollars to the
fisheries I always tried to use hand
dive scallops which is so much better
for the environment
they're sweet delicious and they can
create the most amazing appetizer or
entree what would I do with these I pan
sear them and serve them over a bed of a
cauliflower puree finished with a caper
raisin vinaigrette so Edward what's our
first big challenge for our talented
cooks today thanks Gordon all right
today cooks I want you to open these
four scallops remove the meat from the
ROE and put them on the presentation
board in front of you so you have a
fresh scallop they're closed
there's a little bit of a hinge right
here at the base what you need to do is
release that hinge put the cup side down
slip your knife in there and what you're
doing is you're just gonna rock it back
and forth and you'll hear it kind of
click so now the hinge is released but
the two shells are still stuck together
by the Scout and you're gonna carefully
go in there with your paring knife on
the flat side and gently with the tip of
your knife you're feeling for the bottom
of that show you hear that if you don't
hear that that means you're cutting into
the meat and you should feel the shell
opening up well up see how clean that is
there's your scallop that beautiful
orange
curve that's your row everything else
you can throw away be very very gentle
this is a delicate meat and if you force
anything it will tear the scallop and I
don't want torn scallops with your knife
just scrape it and it'll come right off
the shell and onto your cutting board I
want to release that beautiful scallop
from all of its surroundings most of it
can be just peeled away with your
fingers give it a very quick rinse drain
it on your towel scout now we're gonna
look for that row very gently release it
any membranes cut right off rinse it in
the water
I want to see four scallops beautifully
presented on your board next to the row
okay
back to your stations okay cooks prepare
for a scallop showdown you've got ten
minutes on the clock and unfortunately
we can't stop that clock if you cut
yourself so be mindful please all right
let the battle begin
eirick how do you suss out good scallops
when you're shopping for them make sure
that shell is nice and closed if you see
a shell that's kind of way open means
it's probably not fresh also take that
scallop right up to your nose and smell
it if it smells anywhere near fishy it's
not good it should smell fresh all right
well let's see how they're doing with
their scallop challenge hello there Tara
have you ever done anything like this
people I've shelled oysters before that
how is that challenge different than
this one for you that me comes out in
one poll okay and this you have to kind
of like separate everything so all right
well good luck thank you very much amber
how's it going
it could be going better is there
something new for you're a little bit
tentative there this is definitely
something is it gross no I'm okay with
that
really go in there with your fingers
touch it don't be afraid of it okay work
it hello there tell me how you're
finding this challenge I find this
incredibly satisfying Oh what do you
like so much about it's got color it's
got texture it's got and the challenge
is excruciating ly painful with about
three minutes left that's right yeah
this is slimy let me tell you well don't
let it slip out of your hands keep me
here I'm I'm working okay Richard how's
it going hi I'm struggling what's going
on I can't find what I need to find it's
right there try these scallops all need
to be open they need to be on the board
okay get in there well how is it coming
along
Jennifer I'm trying to replicate chef
Lee's study hand but it's quite slimy is
it it is quite slime yeah alright a
couple down some more to go good luck
Joe thank you all right chef hoody feels
doing well who's struggling Amber's
making them very pretty I feel like
she's getting a little bit tentative
Richards very quiet he's very meditative
Lee going about his business Tara has
never worked with anything like this
before
she's doing okay you know what I worry
about though she's leaving the scallop
in the water too long so once you get
that scalpel is like a sponge it'll
absorb that water and you'll lose
flavors by the cut you got a ninja oh I
think Richard cut himself that's gonna
hurt Richards chances because he's
already kind of behind the clock a
little bit Eric how's he doing eric is
enjoying himself let's see if he can
enjoy himself all the way to the finals
let's find out
I don't like the way she's holding that
knife that is exactly how you cut
yourself put it on the presentation
board please and make it look good
dirty sure there's no membrane on that
scallop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
exercises have attempted to impress chef
Edward with their knife skills but of
course only three can make it through to
the final round time to find out what
chef makes of their efforts all right
amber let's see how you did here and you
got four so you got all of them on there
but see how much is left on your shell
there have all that look at all that
giving me it's almost a whole other
scallops I can't collect that much at a
big show
kudos to getting them all on the plate
you needed a little bit of work on the
presentation okay thank you so what
happened you have problems getting in
there well I couldn't open the hinges
and I struggled with that
it's about delicacy and kind of feeling
that pop so you know they don't listen
the good thing is you've got one and you
got it perfectly done so you know you
just work on your speed thank you I was
a little bit worried because you're
watching them a little bit too much okay
those are really beautiful I just wish
you have gotten that last one on thank
you
you tore the meat a little bit here and
there but nicely done you got four out
of four and pretty good pretty good
thanks chef they're a bit sloppy these
guys just need to be trimmed up no one
wants to eat that
so listen you got three but they needed
to be a little bit cleaner
okay so whose scallop stood out the best
well let's find out who's going through
to the final
[Music]
the first contestant going through to
the final is the third and final
contestant to go through is Tara through
to the finals and unfortunately though
that does mean we do have to say goodbye
to Richard and Jennifer we've really
enjoyed having you here it is not easy
to become a culinary genius as today's
three finalists are discovering but they
must create a dazzling scallop dish so
what are you looking for from our three
finalists I want you guys to really
think about it I want a beautiful
artistic delicious scallop dish you can
sear it you can put it in a stew you can
do so many different things with it
remember you also have that gorgeous row
all right there you have it well no
culinary genius could create a fabulous
dish without ingredients right so behind
you is our pantry it's about to open you
have just two minutes once the clock
starts ticking and your time starts
[Music]
[Applause]
Edward what is in the pantry today
there's rice there's peas there's fresh
mango celebrated grapefruit chervil
tarragon
where's Evenstar nice for a little wild
flavor one minute left make sure you've
been methodical I think I spent a lot of
time looking at everything and then not
enough time picking you're very kind of
Zen and how they're picking like they
have hours to be in the pantry I don't
see enough hands moving hey listen guys
you don't have to pay money for these
things grab what you can it's all free
and reduced looking at the pantry there
are a lot of different things and I'm
not quite sure I'm gonna put them
together I cook very simply so I grabbed
just a few things and probably a few
extra things for color five minutes just
25 minutes to produce a delectable
winning dish let the final battle begins
[Music]
all right amber hello there okay let's
see we're all your ingredients from the
pantry now on the side that's it
well I have to say I completely changed
my strategy I'm gonna go with a seafood
risotto with asparagus tips you brought
something for this one yes
we're drinking and that's something that
actually my mother have always used you
brought your mother-in-law's homemade
spice I did that's getting brownie
points oh good here thank you
timing is really important with risottos
okay I don't want that rice overcooked
all right I don't want it crunchy in the
middle either okay get going you've got
a lot to do here all right hello there
Tara this is a pretty girl that wasn't
from the pantry oh no no I drew this
myself I just brought some fresh garlic
in from my garden cuz that is my best
pantry in my whole house think about the
flavors and how they're all gonna merge
together okay got it and you're a
photographer so make it look fun really
gorgeous all right hello there Erica
what did you grab from the pantry to go
with this I brought some peppers some
shallots some ginger asparagus some
cauliflower and now I'm not gonna use
all you know what your dishes yes I'm
gonna make a scallops with a mustard who
I'm sauce two main ingredients are
experimental the cauliflower puree which
I've never done before and the sauce
make it pretty and delicious taste
before you plate will we'll definitely
do that Thank You Emma wasn't quite sure
herself when she was grabbing for the
pantry but she's decided on a seafood
risotto but you don't want like a creamy
heavy risotto with that delicate scallop
on top cause guess what I'm not gonna
taste the scallop because I'm gonna be
tasting Parmesan and cream only
Tara's gonna make a nice salad with her
dressing the homegrown garlic of all the
ingredients that we've ever seen on this
show I think bringing your own homegrown
garlic is an amazing move and she has to
pair that with a really light delicate
Scout so Eric seared scallop on a
cauliflower puree making a cauliflower
puree is actually really difficult but
it's gotta be velvety smooth to the
tongue we're gonna see very shortly what
would you have grabbed from the pantry
and cooked up today I saw some beautiful
clams and oysters I would have done like
a prefilled mist oh it's out of taking
scallops oysters clams I would have
dredged them deep-frying them taking out
that I'm nice a Oly a little lemon
vinaigrette
against each other and of course the
clock to deliver a scallop dish to
impress Edward let's check them out all
right Tara this is your own garlic from
home yeah so do you grow other things
besides garlic I grow beans tomatoes
onions shallots carrots Oh big it this
garden I'm coming shopping it you're a
pretty big yeah it's a decent size
and if you were to win the title
culinary genius how would that sit with
you what I want to do is donate the
money to a local school garden that's
what they can start a garden because in
the past I've put in a seed of proper
carrot it's like better than giving him
five bucks
what a great thing to do thank you okay
thank you
eight minutes remaining hello amber
you're so quiet
oh really who do you usually cook for
three boys and husband oh that's pretty
much it so I couldn't big me big big
appetites a lot of meats a lot of
burgers
good luck awesome all right Eric how are
you yeah well we'll see the result is
what counts who do you normally cook for
myself my wife and a small group of
friends you are a lawyer by profession
yes now I won't admit it but yes what
are you gonna do to defend your dish if
Edward has some tougher comments I'm
gonna say you're absolutely right chef
what's happening with the fruit yeah
we're just gonna put a little bit of
color on the plate okay you got plenty
of time left I do
think about your dish is this something
you'd photograph and put on the cover of
a magazine yes you would yeah what
magazine is that my
world okay think about it there's
anything you can do you got time okay
I'm plating up early because I'm making
very simple things to eat and I didn't
want to overcook those scallops hey
how's it going did you time it correctly
I just went by what are you gonna do are
you gonna add your Scouts at the last
minute kind of like a garnish all right
give me give me find an extra gear get
it going all right Eric where's your
cauliflower puree it's that's a good
question the way I'll make the puree is
to guess and try to remember things that
I've had before in restaurants to see if
I get it right whoa oh did you taste
everything yes I do
oh you can put that on without tasting
it yes I have taste
all right and good luck good luck okay
it's so-so Thanks one minute just one
minute left
mmm Eric just told you that his sauce
end is putting on his only so-so
and he put it on the plate oh my
goodness amber has to get that risotto
on the plate it's still not done yet
we've got a minute left I am worried
about the time because I forgot to set
my timer Oh how's Tara doing Tara her
salad is looking a little bit too simple
I want some Flair I want some panache
Eric I don't know he's got like a
million pieces of asparagus on there
he's got a lot of things going on that
plate I wanted to clean it up
10 9 8
[Music]
the final part of culinary genius where
now it is time for chef Edward to judge
what these cooks have created so let's
check it out I'm quite happy with the
way that my dish turned out although I
didn't know what I was going to do at
first it all came together quite well I
feel really good about my plate being a
balanced looking meal and I'm hoping
it'll pass to taste blood test I feel
it's a bit crowded I call it creative
chaos all right so just looking at this
I love how you just centered the risotto
on the plate it's very simple it's pure
it's beautiful you're not trying to over
complicate it but it looks nice the
scalpel might be a little bit overcooked
but we're gonna go in there and taste it
you can always tell if a scallop is
overcooked because it loses that glisten
and you actually have a little bit of
glisten left in there so pretty good
your scallops beautifully caramelized
really nicely cooked the inside is
tender really nice cook on that I love
how you only used a little bit of row
because the row actually is very strong
vegetables an actually cook the bacon
actually works in there your risotto is
undercooked and it's a little bit bland
you need to cook it a little bit longer
but overall this is nice I really liked
it thank you
presentation-wise it looks pretty I
didn't like it when you first plated it
and you actually stepped up and did a
few things to change it so good for you
it's nice all right here we go
that dressing is amazing I want more of
that dressing on that that is delicious
pine nuts beautiful touch scallops are
overcooked just a little bit you played
it way too early so your scallops got
cold the only saving grace you have is
that you serve me a salad so it's kind
of okay even though I know he didn't
intend it that way but overall really
nice job thank you
let's see if we got a lot going on here
the plates a little bit busy right now
you could have just as easily done this
for example right and just kind of like
plated it like that medium at meal it'd
be much better scallops cooked really
nicely really tender in the middle
beautiful Roe is cook and I see this a
mustard sauce thing beautiful asparagus
gorgeous cauliflower never want to see
that again in my life that was what you
want to do if you want a velvety puree
raise them in like a chicken liquid put
them in a blender finish with some
butter so but overall the scalps cooked
perfectly and that mustard sauce is
delicious Thank You chefs
many thanks to all of you for a
nail-biting final here Edward has made
his decision
[Music]
to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your cloches I got to tell
you everyone cooked their scallops
perfectly but you had caramelization on
it and that wild garlic you brought from
home pure genius thank you huge
congratulations to today's honor
[Music]